hey you guys how's it going alright so
today I'm going to take a stab at
answering a question that I know as a VC
I think about a lot and many of you who
are either already part of these
billion-dollar companies going to start
one one day or on the path to building
one like how do you do it and then
specifically like look how do you build
it blend our business is really freaking
hard there's no recipe for it but what
I'm going to answer I think pretty
definitively is how do you maximize a
product that you do have to become one
of these enduring billion-dollar
companies this is something that we
think about a ton at Greylock it is it's
our job to find these companies very
very early on figure out the ones that
have potential by looking at the product
and see and see that they actually have
what it takes to become one of these
multi-billion dollar companies of so
just to like speak a little bit to the
track record I don't know how many of
you guys know of Greylock but there are
five companies that were founded after
2000 there are now worth more than 10
billion dollars in the public market and
Greylock has invested in 4 out of 5 of
them and we're talking like super
early-stage Series A Series B so this is
something that we really take seriously
and just to give a few example so
Facebook you know early on we were
investors when it was just you know
still a college only community LinkedIn
we invested in even earlier than
Facebook when it was just you know a
pretty small community of what you know
100 over 1 million members just so you
guys know this thing isn't in it's not
on my on my slides
Airbnb we invested in the series a so
super early on like before it became one
of these you know the company that is
today and it's also my story so when I
was at Bessemer I was investing early
stage series a series B companies and
met the Pinterest team when it was this
small 5 person company 30,000 register
users and just got so excited about the
company that I ended up joining it and
was there for about three and a half
years before joining the Greylock team
and so got to see the company go from
30,000 registered users and kind of like
this kernel of a product to you know the
hundred it's actually one hundred and
fifty million monthly active users that
it is today
and what I've come to realize is that
what it comes down to is understanding
how engagement works in your product so
you know we think about engagement is
like this you know users are just kind
of engaging with our product and they're
just using it but what I what I've come
to realize is that you can think of
users as basically putting fuel or
energy into your product and then the
key to becoming one of these you know
enduring billion-dollar companies is to
take that fuel and turn it into
something that actually powers your
company forward and what I've come to
realize is I the way I think about this
now is basically a hierarchy and so what
I'm going to do through this
presentation is I'm going to talk you
through this hierarchy and what like
some of the things that you guys can be
thinking about if you want to like take
the product that you have now and really
push it to the next level and so the
first level which I'll talk about is
this idea of growing engaged users so
how do you you know we talk about growth
all the time but what's the type of
growth that we should be focused on how
do we make sure that we're encouraging
that growth then I'll talk about just
retaining users and I'll finish it off
by talking about how to make your
product self-perpetuating how to find
and create virtuous loops in your
product that that is really what will
propel your company forward and I think
like if you can really focus on these
three levels you're going to maximize
your chances of building one of these
one of these companies so let's talk
about the first level so I'm sure you
guys all hear you know about growth
hacking this is become like the topic
two-drawer at in Silicon Valley at leas
which is like oh I need a higher a
growth hacker how are you going to
increase downloads for
we going to do to increase monthly
active users and what you end up seeing
and I see this especially from the VC
seat is that there are a lot of
companies that that figure it out they
grow their downloads they grow their
monthly active users and then it kind of
collapsed it's like not all growth is
created equal
and what it what matters is not growing
downloads it's not growing like the
top-line metrics what matters is growing
people that are completing what I call
the core action and so you can think of
that the core action is like the
foundational action in your product like
there should be one you should figure
out what that action is what you
ultimately want your users to do that
creates a foundation of your product and
then you you optimize the heck out of it
to like really get users to do it
so for Pinterest we'd realize that
pinning was ultimately the core action
that if we did discovery right on
Pinterest if we gave you the right pins
that you would like save those pins to
your boards and that creates like this
incredible flywheel within within the
company you know Twitter obviously was
tweeting YouTube you know like the very
innovation that they had early on was
figuring out how to make it super simple
to get content into YouTube which
created this like incredible
self-fulfilling prophecy for them and
when you think through what your core
action is it's really important to
really play through the product roadmap
that it creates so like I think about
Pinterest and if we had chosen
click-throughs as our as our core action
or if we had chosen actually original
pinning so going from outside of
Pinterest and pinning things into
Pinterest instead of repenting things
from within Pinterest the company would
look completely different now so you
really have to be very thoughtful and
intentional about choosing your core
action and if you are growing your
company without growing people
completing the core action like this I
can't emphasize this enough because I
know we made this mistake early on at
Pinterest it just it's like empty
calories like you feel good for a while
because you see this like top-line
metric going up but the end of the day
you're left really with nothing and so
what you should be tracking is not the
lowest common denominator it's tracking
the people that are actually completing
this car action for you
it just optimizes you it focuses you on
the right things and then ultimately the
question you have to ask yourself is the
core action that I have is the
motivation for my users going to be high
enough to do it or is it easy enough to
do and there's some function of this
this I don't know if any of you guys
know Omni re all but he talks about this
this is a BJ Fogg model actually
behavior model but I think that there's
something really to it which is that you
have to motivate your users to get them
over the trigger if you want your
product to grow to a large enough user
base so then let's talk about the next
level so let's assume you've got like
you guys all here must have this already
which is that you've got a growing base
of engaged users now what you're like
what ultimately matters like more than
anything is gaining those users to stick
because look like I see this all the
time there's you know these two
imaginary companies company a and
Company B Company a as you can see it's
growing twice as fast as Company B so
the founders of Company A feel fantastic
but they've got you know they've got
into 80 percent monthly retentions not
that bad losing 20 percent of their
users every month whereas this other
company Company B is only losing 5
percent and so what happens in the first
six months is that company a like if I
invest in company I'd be like yeah
killing it made the right call here but
I'm sure you guys all know how to do
math like what ends up happening is that
after about 12 months in this like
random example that I give the lines
cross because ultimately what happens is
that you're only growing the number of
people that you're losing every month
and so you don't want to have this kind
of like the empty the what's that
expression the empty bucket or the
bucket with a lot of holes in it you
guys know what I'm talking about
leaky bucket so you don't want to have
the leaky bucket so how do you keep on
making sure that you how do you make
sure that you're part of the company B
retention number not the company a
the way that I think about that is with
what I call accruing benefits and
mounting loss so accruing benefits the
idea there is that you want your users
to add data into your product either
explicitly or implicitly and then you
want to kind of recycle that data back
to the user in a way that creates more
value for them so like when I'm on
Facebook and I engage with content on my
newsfeed Facebook's
taking all that implicit and explicit
data and using it to increasingly
personalize the newsfeed for me and
making making it a more engaging product
and whether it's like what I click on or
even who I add as a friend Facebook uses
all that to kind of create these
accruing benefits the flip side is that
you should feel you should have a user
say the more I use a product the more I
have to lose by leaving the product that
you create this experience where I is a
user start to depend on your product I'm
leaving artifacts of myself in the
product so it almost becomes an
extension of my identity or it's
certainly just something where I rely on
it in some way and so to give my
favorite example I mean how many of you
are Evernote users or pocket I'll call a
pocket here also like how many of you
are Evernote users like I don't know
about you guys like I'm freaking
obsessed with this product like every
time there's bad news about Evernote I
like have like this like what's going to
happen to this company because I have
everything in Evernote like it has such
accruing benefits and mounting loss for
me that I just find myself putting more
and more content into Evernote because
now when I do a search I just know that
it's everything for me it's just going
to get better and better and I really
like my my LTV is infinite and I
actually pay the subscription just to
make sure that it stays aren't a little
bit longer because that's that's like my
greatest fear you know Pinterest to like
so when I was at Pinterest I was leading
product for our discovery team and the
thing that I obsessed over was how do I
take the action that my users are doing
and return the
back to them in a way that creates both
the accruing benefits and mounting loss
and what you find is that ultimately now
on Pinterest I hope I hope all of you
are Pinterest users I'm if you're not
please sign up after today it'll make me
feel like I've a job well done but what
you see on Pinterest is that you've got
both this mounting loss which is that
you have you have your boards and it's
all your bookmarks
it's your recipes it's your favorite
articles it's inspiration for a trip you
want to do or what you want to wear and
then your home feed becomes more and
more personalized for you because what
we do is when you pin things to a board
we use that to personalize
recommendations for you and your home
feed so if I like I just bought a new
home now my like home feed is all about
the home decor that I'm thinking about
for my for my empty place or just a
bunch of boxes and so that's the idea
what Pinterest
there's a flip side to this there are
plenty of companies that don't get
through through level two so one of the
companies that I don't know if any of
you guys ever use any of these anonymity
apps like whisper or secret like I
remember when secret came out it was
like so much fun everybody was like
adding secrets on it we were all making
fun of each other
you were like finding out the Silicon
Valley gossip but then what happens is
that you delete the app because you kind
of feel bad about using it and then
someone says like two months later hey
did you see that secret in secret and
you're like okay so your download
secret again you install it and you see
this the secret that the person is
talking about and your product
experience is not any different at that
moment in time than it was two months
ago or if you had been using the product
for two months because there's no
concept of identity there's no concept
of accruing benefits or mounting loss
for me on the other hand Twitter
actually has anonymity like that's
what's creating so many of the problems
that they have right now actually around
trolling and other things but the reason
that they have accruing benefits and
mounting loss is because they have
persistent identity you know you can
create a fake account which accomplished
is some of the part of anonymity but
because I accrue my followers and the
people I follow I have my likes I have
everything else they actually can have
retained users with anonymity at the
same time and so let's talk level 3
because this is the hardest level I
think if any of you guys are growth
people you're probably thinking about
some of the some of the loops here and
so the idea is you know you've got this
growing user base whether it's growing
through word of mouth it's growing
through PR whatever it's causing you to
grow and you're actually you've built a
product that retains those users you've
got accruing benefits you've got
mounting loss people feel like the more
I use a product the more the better it
gets the more I have to lose by leaving
it now the question is just whether you
can create virtuous loops in the product
because this is what really I think
takes a company from you know being you
know a solid player to being one of
those iconic companies the strongest
virtuous loop that I'm sure many of you
guys hear about all the time is a
network effect and so at Pinterest we we
discovered our network effect through
our kind of process of creating the
discovery team just this very simple
idea which is that when a user pins a
pin they either bring a new like website
a new piece of content into Pinterest or
they're actually creating a new edge in
our graph by putting that pin on their
board and what we do then is we take
that data of like this user put this pin
on this board here all the other pins
that share a board with that pin
therefore those are all edges in our
graph and we use that information to
make the discovery experience better
which gets which gets more people to pin
and engage with the product and you've
got like this wonderful virtuous loop
there are other types of virtuous loops
so that you're always going to be
searching for in in your in your company
so you know growth is a great one so
actually one of the things that our
growth team was always thinking about
was people are completing these action
is already on Pinterest and how do we
take advantage of the ripples that they
can create so as an example you know I
use this example of sending a pin here
but I think even a better example is
that you know each pin on Pinterest has
been repinned thousands of times if not
like on average millions of times and
that means that if I find a pin that
you've that there's a recipe like a
pancake recipe that I discover in search
I could show the pin I could show the
person who pinned it be like a super
engaged user who's already getting
notifications all the time or I could
show it like a user who hasn't come to
Pinterest for two weeks and if I pin
that pancake recipe they get a
notification whether it's a push
notification or an email telling them
hey Sarah pinned your pin come see where
she pinned it come see come see the
other pancake recipes that she likes so
and that's like an example of Rhian
gauging the user so look like these are
really hard to create it's um it's uh
there are so many companies that try to
create virtuous loops and just struggle
to unfortunately Evernote my favorite
company is one of those companies so I
don't know if any of you guys have ever
tried to do one of their shared kind of
shared notebooks it just doesn't work
like all the time when I accidentally
press the chat button when really I want
to create a note I just it drives me
crazy but it's Evernote trying to create
virtuous loops in their product but
ultimately it's really a singer player
mode product you know tinder is another
example that I love to make fun of so
tinder you know tinder actually has some
of those re-engagement loops that has
some of the growth loops which is that
if we match I sent it tinder sends a
notification to you letting you know hey
Sarah swipe left on you the problem that
tinder has this is what all dating sites
have is that if you match with someone
and this the reason I make fun of
tenders because we don't actually know
this is what happens on tinder but
ideally you match with someone you have
a successful date with someone and
that's an off-ramp from the experience
it's not actually making the experience
more engaging or kind of creating a
stronger loop and so tinder has to
constantly figure out how do we get
people on the top of the loop to keep
them to keep them dating and so as that
said like you know ultimately the
strongest fuel you can have for your
company is your users doing things in
the product engaging with it in such a
way that they're making the product
stronger both for themselves and for
other people in the company or in the
product and they're also figuring out
how to re-engage your users and grow the
product for you and so last but not
least like how do you measure this like
how do you know if you're on the right
track so we talked about these these
three things you know each of the levels
in the hierarchy and so you know I as an
investor but I imagine you as a product
manager or GM or the CEO of your company
ultimately wants to see these these
three things also which was like am i
growing our users getting more or less
engaged over time so the users I got you
know I bought the site one year ago
versus now what percentage of them are
engaging with the product yeah are we
getting better over time are we getting
worse are the cohorts growing are we
retaining them and ultimately you know
how am i doing on my marketing spend are
we are we getting people through the
through the funnel and so the thing that
I think is like the number one thing to
measure and like everything else in my
view is a waste of time is looking at
cohorts and so you look at cohorts like
at does everybody know what a cohort is
okay good I'm getting some nods but you
know the cohort is just all the users
who joined January 2015 and you track
those we've kind of tagged those people
and you watch them month-to-month just
as their own cohort of users and you see
how many of them every week or every
month or completing your core action and
what percentage of them are actually
completing the core action so you're
getting a sense of both how how many
people are the absolute value how are
they retaining
whether over time your products getting
better at converting the new people that
sign up into people that are actually
engaging with the product and so what
you see is those three things that I
already talked about it really it's like
the distillation of every other metric
that you could you could possibly track
and you know everybody has a different
way that they like to to show it if
you're an early-stage startup or just
getting started with a new a new app I
love line graphs I just find it's like
the easiest way to look at it at a
glance and really understand what's
happening with the company but the more
the bigger you are the further you are
and you're in your kind of user growth
and maturity the more you end up going
to the left and so I think like
ultimately you know if you're able to
track your cohorts you're able to
communicate the value of what you're
doing both to an investor if you end up
coming down this path eventually or
already have or anybody else in your
company so so just to close it out we
talked about the three things in the
hierarchy we talked about what it is
growing in gauges or what you actually
look for what is an engages or focusing
on the core action we talked about the
importance of retaining those users
making sure that you don't have a leaky
bucket and then figuring out ways to
make the product self-perpetuating and I
think that if you are able to build your
product to kind of check the box and
really excel on these three levels I
think you've done everything you can
from a product perspective to maximize
your chances of becoming one of these
iconic companies and so just you know to
close again like you know the biggest
thing I want you guys to take away is
that engagement which is is like this
energy that your users are putting into
the product and it's kind of like the
wind blowing or like the water if you
don't put like the windmill or the dam
you're just kind of losing it like this
energy is there in the product and
you're not taking advantage of it but if
you take advantage of it right it
becomes this like you know just this
fuel for your company
and that's it for me so thanks so much
you guys
[Applause]